Community you really were a blue coat
weren't you I wasn't blue yeah at the
place you showed which was next door to
heesham nuclear power station the thing
is I've got settler because I was I
worked at a really good one in Yarmouth
Great Yarmouth got sacked which is
another story and then uh it was sacked
and then and was sent to we'll move on
to that in a minute
sent to this one sent to that one as a
sort of punishment it was like uh you're
going to Morecambe to do six months
because you have just you've just done
something what had you done
instead of cheeky in the 70s but now is
illegal
it was actually an incident where it was
my first attempt to stand up comedy and
uh what happened was I I'd always wanted
to do stand-up comedy I didn't have the
guts to do it I got very drunk I had a
go at doing it as a blue coat my mate
said to me just copy all the other
comedians at pontins and steal their
jokes and basically talk to the front
row so you're supposed to say where
you're from they say Scotland you say
who paid for your holiday where you're
from Wales you're making noise like a
sheep rubbish jokes right but I said
that's terrible he said don't worry
you're just padding what you're doing is
you're looking for comedy gold which is
where you're from they say Kent and you
say what did you call me right now at
Poltergeist is this used to take the
roof off right
so I tried it but I was very drunk
so I go on stage
and I say where are you from
this bloke says Scotland I can't
remember the joke
hello
from the guy says Wales
I'd black out and I go hi
and then I say anyone in from Kent
bloke shouts out me laughs
and I said
okay
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
Fifty Shades Darker but actually this
isn't darker it's more romantic I would
say yeah I think that's probably true
yeah
um uh yes but there's probably more sex
in it which
I make noises
American accented noises through it
um no there's actually a question though
do they let you do that I mean like when
you're when you're doing the scenes does
the director say
more vocalization
um
they're like no that's not that's not
good no one comes like that
man
[Laughter]
there's some scenes where
they will play music maybe a bit of if
it's a wide shot and it's not like so
it's the closest we get to sort of kind
of sort of just sort of going for it in
one piece
um and they'll play music or something
and my temptation is always just to try
to make Dakota laugh so sometimes I'll
do things like when there's a moment
where I'm meant to you know orgasm I'll
be like
[Laughter]
and was it nice to be this one because
last time it was you and sort of
everyone else was was a woman a director
and everything but this time it's a it's
a man directing that make a difference
no not really to be honest I mean I
think whoever is uh tasked with
directing those kind of scenes I mean
you know these guys know the sex scenes
are awkward anyway and it just needs a
very
this is why I love him
because he includes me and yeah you know
these guys know sex scenes are just
really hard it's like no babe
[Laughter]
what
you did so many films
at some point no no no no I'm back in
The Hobbit no
yeah
a couple of people under that habit but
no no no no no no what is that was that
your decision no
this is based on your life I mean this
is things yeah
Loosely Graham filled with things like
isn't the washing machine that happened
to you what the the washing you were
very hungover oh
yeah
tell Jody Foster that story
all their stories are really cool though
Grail
when I was teaching
this is what this show is based on I I
went home one weekend and I was in my
30s I was probably 33 years of age I
went home to see my mother
and then I went back and while I was at
home my mother did my washing for me
because I was only 33.
and I went back on the on the Sunday
night I got really drunk uh and then I I
went for a curry
and then the next day I went into school
I'm gonna I went into school and it was
a school in Slough and it was quite a
rough school but they had a really
brilliant hearing impaired department so
they were hearing impaired kids who uh
you know struggled they were they were
really looked after in the school anyway
I was really hungover I went there and
about break time I felt really
uncomfortable I thought something's not
right you know so I went to the toilet
and I pulled my trousers down and some
of my mother's knickers had got
I got mixed up in the washing and I was
wearing my mother's
and I went oh God no oh I remember going
are you loser this is such a low point
you [__] loser
and then the curry and the boot the
curry and the booze kicked in from the
night before so I I did like a fecal
Jackson collar
foreign
I started going oh God not this not this
as well oh Jesus so I cleaned myself up
and I pulled my mother's pants back
and I went back into the um classroom
and I saw one of the hearing impaired
kids just looking at me like this and
that's when I remembered that my I had a
microphone directly
here we go
[Applause]
so maybe Man Down isn't that far-fetched
John for you obviously lovely that Emily
wants to be in the absolutely but as a
director is it then weird giving your
life partner notes it was weird because
I was very nervous about it to be honest
I think we both were before we started
shooting she said are you nervous and I
said I'm terrified and she said oh good
me too
um I think it's one of those things
where people think because we're both in
the same business we have the same
experiences but I've actually never been
on set with her seen how she worked I'd
heard she was a diva and I just
can't get Emily out of her trailer stuff
like that it's like oh and um no but I
think what it was is and it sounds
really sappy but it's true I think it's
the greatest collaboration I've ever had
in my career I I've never seen her work
and when you are actually in the room
and she does what she does it honestly
it changes the air in the room everyone
is just completely and totally stunned
by what she does oh yeah
this is what I have to learn early on in
our oh that relationship was it British
people are notoriously terrible at
taking compliments would you agree just
like
um
you weren't cool at all there was none
of that actually I don't know your work
you are a proper fan of it I was full
stalker status yeah I was just like hey
you want to go on a date with me
how many times have you seen Devil Wears
Prada I mean not 75 give or take 72.
yeah no it's one of those things that
back in the day us elderly people used
to channel and um no one does that
anymore
like I said so cruel oh it's just one of
those movies that whatever whenever
you're going through the channels you
just stop and you I mean look has anyone
seen the film hey probably
[Applause]
um
there's a sort of Montage sequence where
Annie Hathaway's got numerous fabulous
outfits that they go through and John
one day I came home and he was watching
it and and he was watching the Montage
bit and he goes
that's my favorite outfit
couldn't get Annie and so I was like
Snoop Dogg's new album bush
a very sexy bit of PR of course that uh
the mighty Pharrell he co-wrote co-write
all the songs he produced the whole
album produced the whole album yes sir
wow now is it true that Pharrell he was
the one encouraging you to be a bit more
family friendly a bit more mainstream
yeah yeah hey
made me change certain words I had a
song called so many hoes he made it so
many Pros
they toned it down
it was just prostitutes no they're
professionals oh I see
silly me
the ladies in the video still look quite
like hoes
okay professional
they're in a video
and then Pharrell is it true that he I
mean I'm sure he enjoyed working with
you but he did have some difficulties
working with you as well yeah when we
were um working on a particular song
called California roll
um Stevie Wonder it came up to the
studio and Pharrell had called a second
hand contact
from being in the studio with me and he
kind of froze he didn't know how to
produce anymore he was stuck he was like
he might have to explain what the yes so
at Pharrell was it an environment
created by Snoop
Pharrell was no longer the same Pharrell
yes he was he was now someone else
he was not he was not the greatest
producer in the world
the guy in the room
so it was Stevie Wonder trying to talk
to him Stevie Wonder was in the mic both
and you know Stevie can't see so Stevie
was waiting on some direction and
Pharrell wasn't giving me no directions
so Tina was just in there just
this is weird and don't answer this
question if you don't want to remember
but I have I don't know why you brought
this up but I did hear you discuss you
had an extraordinary disagreement with
your wife
about yourself do you know what I'm
talking about by myself you mean yes
yeah oh
yeah listen you know this story listen
with interest
one night as you do we were talking
about stuff
I just have no mentioned and of course
being circumcised I said
they were chatting they're married
they're married they're allowed
she said
she said you're not circumcised
I said what do you mean you've only
known me if you I I all my life I
remember my mother telling me why
because it was fashionable at the time
she said you're not circumcised I said
that's ridiculous I should know if I'm
circumcised
end of conversation but the next day I
happened to be seeing my doctor
are you okay
I was seeing my doctor about my annual
physical of course so uh well he was
down there
I said excuse me oh by the way of
um my wife and I had a little
disagreement um
I I am circumcised am I because she says
I'm not and he goes
not
[Applause]
it's not possible so he looked down
again and he said hey I'm Jewish I know
the difference
what is that that is a bizarre
[Laughter]
you're gonna have to change your
Facebook status
no more beef stew
well there's more beef stew
because when uh you were starting off in
wrestling you had a Persona that am I
right well sort of half man half machine
was that the idea correct yes this was
Prototype it was awful
so you you want to try to find a Persona
or here's some more inside baseball for
a gimmick where is it describes you as a
character so like when you walk out
people notice you and they kind of you
can describe your character but these
are not gimmicks these this is real whoa
whoa I mean if they work yes but you
kind of it's It's a trial and error
process with a lot of errors and uh and
my first try was uh the Prototype which
was half man and half machine and 100
crap
but given that you're not half a machine
how did you demonstrate you were a
machine well I I used this ability to
talk rather monotone and would say
things authoritative and just when I
said I would kick your ass at the
fairgrounds on Sunday I would rewind it
and say it again for you Roy didn't they
say I would kick your ass at the
fairgrounds that didn't work
you no
no it didn't that's a good one everybody
but but it worked on one I have one
you found a huge success as John Cena
imagine that I figure I need to come up
with some sort of name yeah look
every wrestler has a name yes and people
think that like hey man how'd you make
up the name John Cena
I was like no dude I would have made up
like dick hammerbush or something cool
like that
camera or something I don't know
[Applause]
from there no one's letting you go out
with
I would but uh they actually think that
John Cena is a gimmick name but no
that's actually through all the the
presentation that is WWE I'm stuck with
you wrestling fan Jimmy I used to love
wrestling uh when we were much younger
about the same time as Transformers back
in the day we had big daddy
yeah the giant haystack
[Applause]
no I used to love it I thought it was
just fantastic by the way I'm John Cena
that is awesome names the ultimate
drooler or like nothing and dresses like
to have uh signature moves and things
yeah and one of yours is the you can't
see me but that's correct is that true
that came out of your family somehow
yeah I was dared to do it so I was
actually making the music for my own
theme song that you just so heard and
finally serenaded me to thank you very
much uh and we played it for my brother
and the first time he heard it this was
uh the the 50 cents crew had a really
popular song called in the club and he
heard it the first time and instead of
dancing like he was our litmus test to
see what songs were good what songs are
bad he did this
and I'm like dude what are you doing
he's like no everybody does this man
everybody does this and I guess this is
from 50 cents video and he's like you
won't do it on TV
what the hell do I Gotta Lose am I going
to fire me of course I'll do it on TV
but instead of doing this I did this
and now for 15 years
because of a dare
I've been doing this
and I'll do you one better people
actually think I'm invisible there will
be people to look at this couch and be
like why is there nobody next to
McConaughey
and John Cena would be there but we
can't see him
so you never know you remember Hacksaw
Jim Douglas King Kong bunny
care Von eriks and carry the cloth
I got kicked out of first time I'm
talking Texas wrestling I get kicked out
of her Coliseum in Shreveport for
pelting scandar Akbar the bag of
tomatoes
skandar Akbar was a man dressed as a
Sheik that used to throw fire yes and he
managed King Kong Bundy who was like 484
pounds and remember there's missing
Lanes from Parts unknowns that are the
green face spit green mystery they sound
really good good stuff yeah entertaining
it is so much fun and I'm John Cena
[Music]
hello hi what's your name uh James James
lovely James and what do you do I'm a
civil servant a civil servant lovely in
London here uh yes in London are you
from the London area uh no I live in
London but I'm originally from um
Suffolk oh oh yeah it's a Suffolk
massive yeah
is he mentioned in the song probably
yeah what what school did you go to
um so I went to brandiston oh sweet yeah
I went to Primary School yeah oh okay
did we know each other yeah did we
[Applause]
think
James hello yeah James yes me that's the
one what the [__]
do you know it's my best mate growing up
and now you're talking to me on a
monitor
specs and he's like oh my God no can we
not flip him and just get him out of
here
do you have a story or do you well yeah
I did but please let it be about Edge
we'll flip you and then
Okay
cool so um yeah this is so randomly
it's really weird um yeah when we were
younger Ed used to come around to my
house and yeah like you're saying we
used to be quite good mates
um and I remember one time
um one time he was coming around for tea
um and I forgotten to tell mum who's a
vegetarian
um at that point anyway and um so mum
cooked I think the sausage and mashed
for tea
um and Ed said you know after the meal
these are the best sausages I've ever
tasted you know where did you get them
from and Mum had to lie because she had
no clue
um and so yeah 16 years later I'm really
sorry first time I ever had me and also
the first time I ever watched The
Simpsons episode was around your house
as well
okay well done we're going to flip you
now and then uh we could be reunited
backstage
[Applause]
surprise surprise
me
[Applause]
um
have a seat have a seat dude
yeah
one of the things you can do is you can
conjure up uh people's fears yes okay
yes so you you're afraid of quite basic
things I'm afraid of like most things
like anything high risk I'm terrified of
but those are rational things okay
irrational is big spiders because but
they actually
um I become paralyzed when I when I have
a spider in my room really yeah I like
wish I were tougher than that but I'm
not okay now walk or flow were you
serious when you told us what your fear
is I mean it is it's a good fear it's I
think it's a founded fear I think it's a
founded fear it is tell us what it is
um I have a phobia being chased around
with poop on a stick
[Laughter]
I'd say we've all got that fear
there's another one that goes not a lot
for that
it started when I was a kid
it was just weird parenting
for some reason kids thought it was
funny to stick a stick in dog poop and
Chase each other around with it
but that scared the crap out of me
because of the cleanliness problem of it
no spreading terms
[Laughter]
granted though yours is brilliantly
specific and I think without knowing it
I think we probably all share it we may
I don't know I I didn't have the the
fear when I was younger because we've
all we all go through this but it's when
a little child and I'm the oldest of
seven kids and I got a lot of little
Rugrats running around and these little
roaches start losing their teeth and
they get a little Wiggly and they like
to show me like this little dagger
flipping in and out of their mouth and
like look up does everybody want to pull
this thing out I'm like get out of here
you're freaking me out
but don't you think that is really
freaky it's like her thumb
it just really kind of grosses me out
the cutest little thing on the planet
starts to do like the creepiest thing in
the planet and I'm like get out of here
it's like here tie the string to my
thing to the doorknob get out of here
creep
animals
that's now
little ones running around flipping
their little fake teeth falling out look
we all have this you know when you you
have the dreams your teeth pull out I
don't know what it means anybody what it
means we get bigger ones no you had a
bad dreams am I the only the only one
that's bad
I haven't just had that dream too yeah
not me what does that mean I think I
don't know share of money I think I
think that's what they do who has fear
of money
maybe I'm just afraid of my teeth
[__] falling out
[Applause]
sorry
what are you afraid of well I was gonna
go with flying but I think I'll go with
um girls over 12.
[Applause]
[Laughter]
I
don't know what came over here
the last minute of my life I wouldn't
have predicted that
how was it Mark Ruffalo you're not going
to believe what he said to me
he was bang on the money
perceptive man
it was the Dora poem don't try and
justify it
do you know what I've always hated the
hulky [__]
don't make him angry yeah you would like
me when I'm angry buffalo
I my son said that to me the other day
when he was mad at me what that you
wouldn't like him even I always hated
the Hulk I think he's [__]
you just told him that he was afraid of
girls over 12.
for him that would be okay
hi what's your name my name's Sebastian
Sebastian and where are you from I'm
from Newcastle Newcastle okay do you
live there or here uh I live in
Newcastle yeah okay all right off you go
with the story Sebastian well many moons
ago
um uh I actually went to school in
Newcastle
um and there was a disco coming up that
was a really popular girl at school
um usual sort of scenario all the you
know all the guys after it
um I sort of like waited to the last
moment last couple of days
um and asked a girl one of this popular
girl question if you'd like to go with
me
and she said yes this was literally I
think the day before the Disco
um lo and behold the turns out that she
was actually gonna go with somebody else
um and that other person was actually
Charlie Sebastian lippiat
come on
[Applause]
come to two people
Rachel Gould
they're very same yes you know who it is
wow you know at the time
and did you end up marrying Rachel Gould
uh no not yet no okay it's still time it
all happened to have a sword with you do
you
you you could you could have Revenge if
you want to do you want to
there you go
if we thought we'd seen you play
Everything But first which
mostly [__]
yeah my first witch but I hear you went
through a phase you got offered a lot of
witches when I was 40 when I turned 40 I
was offered three which is in one year
and it was sending me a signal I felt
about Hollywood and how they felt about
people turning 40.
so I felt uh bad and I and it made me
sort of I had like a little my back up
you know and so no I didn't want to play
them so A lot's changed in the last five
years for you good
oh
yeah
[Applause]
[Laughter]
that scene in episode one The Doctors
thing yeah did that really happen yeah
my mum will kill me for telling this
because it was my uh uh our family
doctors and I
he'd been our family my doctor since I
was a child and but I went to as an
adult because
I was there was something wrong with my
bum
why when you said bum you looked at me
directly in the eyes I'm sorry
there was something but there was
something wrong with my
bun
and I was a I said there's this thing
wrong with my bum and he went okay and I
went so what'd you say he goes well
it'll probably be all right
I
would really like it I'd like you to
just if you could make me feel better
about if I feel better that it will be
all right and he went it it'll probably
clear itself up and I said yeah but
is there any way I could be sure when he
went ah
you want me to put my finger up there
don't you
magically
the other I think maybe maybe there's a
reason but what is the reason that you
film it in the school you used to teach
in I think it's therapy probably I'm in
the actual classroom where I talk
because I was just to keep the theme
going a real teacher for a long time
yeah I talked for yeah but six years in
the school that we filming in the
classroom that I'm going Madden and I
that's that's real that was my classroom
yeah but you did it for did you ever
enjoy it was there ever a moment when
you thought I like this I don't know
okay
well I met some very nice people there
and
it was like you were nominated for
Teacher of the Year weren't you yes I
was great
yeah you know yes I've told this story
many times but to teacher of the year is
a very prestigious award that's taken
very seriously and rightly by the
hard-working teaching community and my
head teacher called me in and he was
wetting himself laughing he couldn't
stop laughing for the first 10 minutes
and he went I went what why have you
called me here he goes you've been numb
eliminated
and I went oh okay and it was by a very
sweet girl called Gemma I've humiliated
many times and it's a six-page document
that people have to fill in for the
reasons why you should be nominated for
Teacher of the Year it was blank
from one sentence that she'd written on
it which was the reasons why you think
he should be teacher of the year and
she's written he's a well good laugh and
he don't make us do no work
thank you
your character's name is Dr smolder
bravestone yes and so all the characters
have strengths so one of your strengths
is the smolder an actual smolder yes it
just takes over uh and I have no control
of it and did you know you could smolder
like did you kind of think yeah when you
were doing you read it you got to go oh
yeah I'll do my smolder you know I take
you is that it no it didn't come yet oh
okay okay that literally is where it
came from that what you're saying and
this is why he looked at me because it's
so frustrating just go ahead tell the
story about your stupid smoke
it's one of those things that you know
as we're developing the script and
thinking well what could be a fun thing
well what of a fun thing one of the fun
things was he he has this ability to
smolder and it just takes over him he
has no control of it uh and uh and it's
just one of those things Graham that God
delivered I signed for it and then
just do it and everyone everyone loves
it and everyone loves it except one
individual
everyone loves I'm gonna tell you what
it is okay now we we are we are very
close we're very close as friends and
you know in this position he's a
producer on a film so sometimes I just
bit my tongue so this idea came up from
a producer like mentality oh you know
what would be great for this character
if he's smoldered and I was like what
you know if he did a thing and I was
like well that got to do with that being
like in the game he's like it's a thing
and he's like and then he's brought him
back he was like my mom used to do it to
me when I was
and that's why we listen to him
everything got tied back to Hawaii
that's how he did it Greg could we see a
smaller can we see oh I'd be happy to
Great sit back for a second
yeah
all right here we go can we have a
little music maybe something that's a
little ominous okay here we go wow yes
okay okay here we go you can do it to me
get ready here we go
[Music]
[Laughter]
beautiful very good
thank you thank you so much that
sustains smoldering it's very impressive
[Applause]
is pregnant
having a baby
Rebels Pebble
it's a little wrong that's good yeah
it's a little rock that's why you are
who you are
Heaven obviously you're like not just a
stand-up you're like a stand-up
Superstar you sell out Arenas all over
the world the best of our time
[Applause]
but what's nice to know is it wasn't
always like that I don't know like what
was it what did you perform it you
performed at a seafood festival I mean
which which [__] show you want to know
about
I
had a crab fest
what is that in the beginning of the
stand of Comedy you're not you're not
performing in in luxury you know venues
wherever they feel that they can build
the stage and make money is where you're
going so there was a crab fest
comedian Talent I was like all right
well you know I'm available
I don't know if you guys have ever tried
to tell a joke about people cracking
crabs
it's not the best environment
literally the frustration that comes
from not being able to open a crabs
funny at the same time the stuff that
you hear I remember hearing a woman an
older lady who was like she was cracking
cracks because this is how you crack
crack
[Music]
I tell a joke and the joke doesn't work
and I remember this lady just going oh
no
[Laughter]
the disappointment
from her voice
she said baby it was like oh no baby
as if I have made a mistake with my
choice of life like I'm not doing it
wrong I I mean you know look the the the
the hardship that I went through has
helped helped build me into the person I
am today where I can take so much but
I've been through it all I was I was
hitting the face with a buffalo wing
I performed don't perform around food
let me go to my shows now there's no
food
uh it was it was a it was actually a
male strip club that they shut down for
comedy for the first half so it was like
it was a bunch of it was ladies in there
and you know it's just supposed to be us
performing for these women that were
riled up first thing I got on stage when
they introduced me and this lady was
like pull it out I said hey
[Applause]
that's not me I'm not here
to entertain these jokes
I know who's got kids I started trying
to merge into kid material and there's
one dude from the back I just remember
this dude from the back he was like
that's enough and he's just threw a
buffalo wing at me
right here buffalo sauce is hot sauce
I assumed that it was a woman with a
deep voice so I was like who threw it
who threw it because at the end of the
day I'm a man I'm a man first don't
disrespect me
he stood up and he was like I did it and
I I contemplated just taking my clothes
off I was like
[Applause]
yeah well I I collect um stuff from
movies uh that some of the movies I've
done but really mainly Star Trek
memorabilia because I love Star Trek
nerd
no I've never been in a Star Trek but I
love the Original Series so I have like
I have the Gorn head from the original
series from the episode Arena
what the Gorn is the Gorn from Star Trek
we're going to give you the golden head
oh wow okay do you have any of the
boulders do any of the boulders I don't
have any of the light Boulders no but I
have Spock's ears from yeah
[Applause]
yeah
very good but on bridesmaids you did do
a lot of kind of proper bonding on
bridesmaids didn't you didn't you like
Party nights and stuff we we did a pre
um my co-writer Annie and I had the idea
to get all the girls together plus the
script supervisor wardrobe just all like
the women on the film to buy 40. there
were a lot of people 40 women yeah
me is research
we went to a gentleman's entertainment
yeah parlor
strip club well guys yeah okay so we got
in a we got a party bus
es a lot of booze weird poles which I
was like did it have the Disco lights in
the Box oh yeah oh fabulous yeah and
then we went to we went to a strip club
um and
um
there was like a backdraft yeah it
wasn't that it would all come out in
like fireman stuff and then it was like
right like everything had the same theme
and everything involved it seemed like
every number had a duster everybody had
a long trench coat a lot of equipment
do you remember the uh The Matrix one
yeah there was somebody was playing Neo
wonderfully
there was a lot of long trenches and
guys in suits and everybody had these
very cheap glasses on but I couldn't
figure out the one guy had a huge huge
thick rope around his waist and I was
like I have not seen The Matrix in a
while I couldn't figure out
we're all like what's the Rope about I
don't remember a rope in The Matrix and
they're like dude these synchronized
dancing and it's like all this encloses
coming off we're like put it off
[Laughter]
I'm still like I don't get what the Rope
is about and then the big move comes
where you know the bullets come and he
does like the back bend clearly this
professional dancer could not do a back
bend so the big move was like all of a
sudden it's like oh and somebody off
stage is clearly holding the road
thank you
[Applause]
held this guy up because he was like
okay that was my that was yes that was
like a stand that moment a lot of things
and now Saturday Night Live also was a
big bonding thing now because Christian
do you know Leslie and
Cake
we met I think we met when I posted oh
no we and we did a movie together
um and we worked together after that
okay yeah okay but now you guys are
still in Sacramento life most people I'm
sure no but it's a it's a big comedy
sketch show in in America but how long
we worked together for how many years
now it's been two after one right it's
been three maybe three it's been three
um after the first year Leslie and my
name is Kate McKinnon and she uh I know
that but uh she she came up to me and
she said um after a year of knowing me
um
you all right Kate Middleton
thank you
and were you joking uh no I was not
I was like my kid I was like well who's
Middleton then she was like a princess
[__]
[Applause]
I like Kate Middleton oh her hair is
awesome
okay he did some you did some great
characters on Saturday Night Live you're
Justin Bieber Justin Bieber is spookily
accurate
[Applause]
thank you you've done it in front of him
haven't you I have not you haven't have
not breached
um I met him before because he hosted
SNL once and then uh that was before I
started doing the impression of him but
I was so struck by how this was before
he got really beefy for those Calvin
kleinance and now he looks like you know
a big Beefcake but
um he was really he was very delicately
very tender beautiful just such a
beautiful face and such a big big hat
such big clothes and just the most
beautiful and I I am a huge fan of his
and I love it now you have a special way
of a special way of preparing the face
haven't you yes
um yes you you want to look as though
you've done something wrong but like
laughs
[Music]
very good
so now how old are you now I'm 77 and I
don't know
don't don't
know
[Music]
I think they implore because they know
they're going to live longer than me
in New York they perks it needs to be a
new apartment on the market soon
I hate when people say like oh there's
77 years young I met Vanessa Vanessa
Felts and she said to me is Joan she's
77 years young and I want to say and
here's Vanessa and she's 350 pounds thin
[Applause]
it sucks and you have to face it
and you have these I've been on this
show with some of these older women that
still try to look good no names Goldie
Hawn
[Applause]
she's my friend and she says to me would
you believe I got a grown-up daughter
and you go yes
I love your skirt your nipples are
showing I mean
there goes the goldie horn booking
age sucks have you got a face but is it
because America is really so youth
obsessed I mean how and in the film you
show you know kind of that it is hard
for a woman of your age to get the job
it's beyond difficult the only jobs
really left now for women unless they
get friendly with people to do films but
the only jobs that are really
commercials I just thank God my I made
my yearly not this year on a product
called girly which is for dry vagina and
it's um
well anyone knows the Heartbreak of dry
vagina
thank you
[Applause]
I was perfect for it like cattle's
following me home
oh wow
three Jewish men are trying to rent my
uterus instead of going to Miami
but and this
thank God for these commercials there's
one called an uh Zestra is that come
here yet
women's Viagra has that happened yet
it's women's Viagra and they have this
big discussion with me should they make
it in pill form this is honest to God
truth it was in the newspapers pill form
or cream because they didn't know which
would do better and they find a side of
these idiots will do it in cream because
if it's in pill form in a bar a man can
drop it in a woman's drink and she won't
know it but if you're in a barn a guy
goes so where are you from
too
[Applause]
should we do another thing uh we loved
you as the genie in Aladdin well that
was fun so we thought we might have our
very own genie on the show tonight so uh
is there anyone in the audience who
fancies a go at being a genie
too okay try try you uh what what what's
your name Ewan sorry what yeah
his name is urine
nice to have you here thank you no
worries great area
frightening I know don't piss off Ewing
okay
don't think of a magic word right
something you know it's just you magic
word and that camera three is going to
do a kind of Zoom crash on you so so
when I say go you and you'll just do
your magic word okay so you and go
hi Graham
[Applause]
wow
how grandma would feel like we're in the
middle of a Telethon right now
Ewan has learned to say hi Graham thanks
to your dollars
please help we'll learn another phrase
by the end of the show
is should we should we try another boy
oh actually you're wearing blue already
that's why you yeah okay so into that
camera your magic world what's your name
Nick good Nick okay
number three and go Alakazam
wow
it was almost it was almost too good it
was a bit like you're you're very good
at that yeah Alakazam time to dance now
I'm gonna dance with you and and good
night
um
[Applause]
there you go
so I'm just gonna get my genie to help
me okay hang on oh yes because I forgot
all about poor creatures
[Applause]
good Nick good oh there he is
ready I need I need a lovely funky DJ
console please
[Applause]
good work good work Nick okay I'll tell
you what Nick you you can come back into
the studio come back to the studio you
can help us in this thing okay there you
go well done
[Applause]
yeah right I must be floating anymore
thank you okay we go over here for the
DJ bro right here we go here we go it's
it's the Robin and Graham Road Show
hello loads of gloves okay you're over
there now well done so there's a mic
there now Nick I've got some music Nick
put a shout out right now Nick beer now
for the blue people they're gonna keep
it real get ready for an Alakazam
[Applause]
so it's the Robin and Graham Road Show
can you do a jingle a live jingle for us
welcome to the Robin and Graham radio
show
very good
shout out from Nick okay
good evening Robin
welcome back once again we got some
shout outs I got one going on right now
to Stephen Buck he wants to shout out to
Jess who's your best friend and he says
stop texting him he's not interested
[Applause]
Michelle Smith Michelle Smith wants to
shout out to Esther best friend that
bloke you pulled don't worry about
trying to remember his name you can do
so much better yeah
[Applause]
there he is it Marlon if anyone gonna
say we'd like to shout out to his friend
Gregoire don't worry girls love that you
have got a third nipple
[Applause]
[Music]
you don't have to
[Applause]
go
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait yeah yes first of all I'm
not a circus freak
[Applause]
secondly I will get my third nipple out
on the condition that Robin Williams
comes and touches it
oh [__] here we go
there we go
this better be a real nipple
[Applause]
ready
oh boy please let it be a nipple
[Applause]
ready ready here we go okay
oh
[__] I did
wow beautiful wow
[Applause]
you've got another one
play with my third nipple girl you've
never had fun till you go third
once you've got the third nipple things
get crazy
the two nipples going but when the third
goes
[Music]
I'm certain nipple goes and then my
fourth penis jumps out
ladies and Gentlemen please thank my
guest tonight they're Fantastic Mr Robin
Williams
hey man
everybody thank you
now Sir Patrick Stewart and you don't
really use this so much do you
uh
what should I sorry should I have been
calling you no I shouldn't am I supposed
to no okay but but no do you I take my
lead from Sir Ian I whom we've both
shared some time with yes and uh he is
he is so phlegmatic about all of that
and and I just you know it's a great
honor but it's not something that I need
to press when you bump into another sir
when you're out and about do you then do
you do you call each other well yes sir
you must work roll in sir circles okay
circles
[Applause]
so how do you become a sir
um well Patrick how
well you know it's a case of um
I got mine on the Queen's birthday
honors but you have reminded me that I
did have a sir encounter only a few
weeks ago in Los Angeles a rather fancy
in fact extremely fancy restaurant tell
me what it is because they'll know
um it was the uh the the the Tower bar
I'm not damn
[Applause]
it
keep going you keep going keep going
okay now the towel bar is a spot I got a
feeling this isn't gonna work out
four of us were seated at a table about
15 minutes later into the restaurant
walks Sir Paul McCartney wow good now
Paul and I have a very slender
relationship but it's lasted decades I
first encountered him in
1964. no when his girlfriend Jane Asher
then told him that I loved Aston Martins
I was driving a battered old Ford but
Aston Martin's were my dream car she
told him this and one night yeah we knew
he was seeing the show there was a knock
on my door and I said yeah come in I'm
there in my underwear you know like as
usual
in my pants
I'm ready for you
come in and the door open and standing
there was Paul McCartney who I had never
met before and this was 1964. and uh he
said James says that you like Aston
Martin's here drive this wow and he
tossed a bunch of keys that was pretty
cool and it was an ass it was his
name anyway do you want to hear the rest
let's keep going keep going we're in
we're in the fanciest restaurant in L.A
we're now in the tower bars we are
he sees me and comes over and uh I stand
up and say hi and we have a big hug in
the restaurant and I'm very much aware
that there's all the tables are full on
this kind of thing and we talked for
five or six minutes and he goes and sits
down five minutes go by and into the
restaurant
walks a Ringo Starr I swear to you I'm
not making this when were they together
they were they were oh they were at the
same table they were the same yes
um well uh we uh at the tower
I am expecting so many free meals
we finish early and I get up to go and
Paul stands up to say goodbye and we
have a hug and this we have a hug he
says into my ear
do you know Ringo
I've never met him but I'm he said oh
boy Ringo come on come over here
hang on a minute he said sir Ringo
Sir Patrick Sir Paul hey we've got the
Knights of the Round Table
[Applause]
[Music]